[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض هذه ابرز عناوينها
ونحن جاهزون
للعمل مع الاطراف
للبحث عن الحلول السلميه وقد سبق خطوه
سعوديه جديده في ازمه اوكرانيا وزير
الخارجيه يؤكد استعداد الرياض للوساط
وموسكو ترحب
رياض تدشن ملتقى بيبان 23 بطوله عالميه
لرواد الاعمال واكثر من مئه الف مشترك
ازمه جسر الملك فهد في شرق السعوديه مستمر
تعطل يربك حركه السير ولا تجاوب حتى الان
في الرابعه ايضا
السعوديه تعلن السماح للمقيمين في دول
الخليج بتاشيره سياحيه تتيح لهم العمره
والاستثناءات في المهن
كثير من الانتظار لهذه القمه الكبيره
والمنتظره
صراع صداره في الدوري السعودي يشتعل
الاتحاد يلاقي النصر على ملعب الجوهره في
جده
دبلوماسيه اخرى لوزير الخرجات السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان هذه المره الى موسكو
اكد من خلالها وفي مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره
الروسي
ان السعوديه جاهزه للقيام بما يلزم لحل
الصراع في اوكرانيا ومستعده لتسهيل الحوار
بين موسكو وكيف من جهه رحب وزير الخارجيه
الروسي بموقف السعوديه مؤكدا انها تسعى
لايجاد حل مناسب للازمه وانا دور الرياض
لا يقتصر على تبادل الازرق
نسعى دائما لدعم كل ما من شانه
الوصول الى تسويه لهذا الصراع ونحن جاهزون
للعمل مع الاطراف
للبحث عن الحلول السلميه وقد سبق انساهمنا
فيما
حصل في من تبادل السجناء
والذي اشرف عليه اسمه العهد مباشره بتعاون
مشكور من الجانب الروسي
فنستمر في البحث عن الفرص المتاحه
لتسهيل الحوار
تطرقنا لمناقشه عده قضايا في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا موسكو رياض متفقان على ان
الحل السياسي هو الافضل لكل القضايا
العالميه بمشاركه جميع الاطراف نحن نقدر
عمل اصدقائنا في السعوديه والدور الذي
تلعبه المملكه في المنطقه
ولد افتتاح جلسه المباحثات الثنائيه قال
وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان ان المملكه تسعى لتعزيز وتطوير
العلاقات مع روسيا على جميع الاسعده واضاف
خلال افتتاح جلسه مباحثات مع نظيره الروسي
ساجلا بروف في موسكو انه يتطلع ان تسهم
نقاشات اليوم في توحيد الرؤى والدعم
العلاقات الثنائيه
اليوم على ارضيه من التاريخ الممتد لعلاقه
متميزه بين ما لدينا ونتطلع مباحثاتنا
اليوم والتعاون الذي يتم بين المسؤولين في
البلدين في توحيد الرؤى ودعم العلاقات
الثنائيه لمجالات ارحب وفقا لتوجيات قياده
حي البلديه وان نتبادل وجهات النظر حول
الازمات المختلفه الدوليه واقليميا
انضم الينا في استديوهاتنا من رياض عضو
مجلس الشورى واستاد العلوم السياسيه
الدكتور ابراهيم النحاس اهلا وسهلا بك
دكتور ابراهيم
دكتور دانا اولا نقرا في دلالات هذه
الزياره ولنحاول ان نربط هذه الدلالات
بخطوات السعوديه الاخيره لقاء الخارجيه
البريطاني رحله لوزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الى كييف
وزياره يقوم بها رئيس الوزراء البولندي
الى الرياض ثم وزير الخارجيه السعوديه في
موسكو ماذا تريد الرياض من خلال هذه
الخطوات نعم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والرياضه عن طريق وزير خارجيتها في هذا
اليوم تريد ان تذهب بالاتجاهات التي تؤدي
الى
تعزيز
المسائل يتعلق بالامن والسلم والاستقرار
الدولي وهذه الدلالات الدائمه التي تعمل
عليها المركبه بالسعوديه اذا ربطنا هذه
المبادئ العامه التي تعمل عليها سياسه
السعوديه
بالحراك السياسي والدبلوماسي الذي اشارته
اليه استاذ خالد قبل قليل هي تاتيب باهميه
التعامل مع مثل هذه الاطراف الدوليه سواء
الدول العظمى
على سبيل المثال وروسيا في هذا التوقيت او
الدول التي تدخل في علاقات جيده من قبل
السعوديه وايضا داخله في او قريبه من
مناطق الصراع كابولندا او الزياره الى
اوكرانيا الاخيره واللقاء وزير الرايه
الرئيس الاوكراني المملكه العربيه
السعوديه حريصه ان لا تتصاعد مثل هذه
الازمات الى مستويات اعلى وقد تؤدي هذه
الازمات في حاله تصاعدها الى مسائل قد
تخرج عن نطاق السيطره الدوليه حتى للاطراف
المتصارعه سواء كانت هذه الدول الكبرى او
عظمى ولذلك بالسعوديه كدوله دائما ما تدعي
تدعم الامن والسلم والاستقرار تذهب بمذهله
جهه يضاف الى ذلك ان المملكه تاريخ
وعلاقات جيده مع جميع هذه الاطراف التي
تتسارع في هذا التوقيت وهذا الذي يجعل
منها دوله مقبوله في ان تكون وسيطا للسلام
وبسيطا لحل النزاعات ودوله لديها من
النماذج الايجابيه الكثيره في تخفيف حده
العنف والصراعات ولعل وزير الخارجيه اشار
الى مساله تخفيف النزاعات وان لا تتصاعد
المسائل الى مسائل اعلى بشكل او باخر يضاف
الى ذلك انه دلاله مهمه جدا ان تكون هذه
الزياره ايضا لروسيا الدوله العظمى الدوله
الكبرى في المجتمع الدولي التي ترتبط ايضا
بعلاقات ممتاز هي دلالتها ان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ليست دوله تحزبات سواء
للشرق او الغرب وانما دوله تعمل مع جميع
الاطراف الدوليه ووظفت هذه العلاقات
الدوليه وحسن تاريخها مع المجتمع الدولي
بان تكون دوله للسلام ودوله تستطيع الى حد
ما نقل هذه الرسائل بين هذه الدول
والتخفيف من حده التوتر بين هذه القوى
العظمى التي تؤثر في المجتمع الدولي وايضا
تؤثر حتى في المستويات الاخرى جميع
المستويات لعلي يشير هنا نقطه مهمه انه
دلاله المملكه العربيه السعوديه ايضا نذهب
تذهب باتجاهات انها دوله اسلاميه ومركز
العالم الاسلامي وذلك يعني ان الصوت ثقل
اكبر هذا نعم كبير جدا بان العالم
الاسلامي بمجموعه لا يتمنى ان تذهب هذه
الصراعات الى مستويات اعلى والامه العربيه
ايضا من المملكه العربيه ممثله العربيه لا
تتمنى ان تذهب هذه الصراعات المستويات
اعلى وبالتالي هذا الثقل الكبير معكر
بالسعوديه نقطه اخرى ان المملكه في مجموعه
العشرين ونحن كمجموعه العشرين والمملكه
احدى هذه الدول يجب ان نكون بنات للتنميه
والامن والسلم والاستقرار وليس في اتجاهات
النزاعات هذا ما تحاول ان تعمل عليه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بتوظيفها
لعلاقاتها باعراض جميع الاطراف وبتوظيف
ايضا الدبلوماسيه التي تملكها ولخبراتها
وايضا دعني اقول القياده السعوديه حفظها
الله تاريخيا وحتى القريب ساهمت باحلال
الامن والسلم والاستقرار عن طريق اطلاق
الاسرع هذه تعطي المملكه قبول على اعلى
المستويات بان تكون وسيطا دائما للامن
والسلم والاستق بسيطا ايضا مقبولا لدى
جميع الاطراف لكنه وزير الخارجيه الروسي
لظروف المؤتمر الصحفي كان واضحا الى حد
رحب بالموقف السعودي بجهود الوساطه التي
تقوم بها على كل المستويات وبالذات في
الازمه او الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه لكنه
قال بان باب المفاوضات الان والسلام مغلق
فبالتالي هذا يعني ان الامور تتجه لما هو
اخطر ربما الى الخروج عن نطاق السيطره هنا
عندما اخذنا هذا السيناريو دكتور وهو
سيناريو الاكثر ترجيحا بناء على المواقف
على الارض الان هنا كيف يمكن ان تنظر
الرياض الى السيناريوهات وعلى اي اساس
ستبني مواقفها في هذه نعم هو مثل هذا
التصريح الذي تفضلتم عليه لم يعني اقول
نحن كراعي عام على المجتمع الدولي لم
نتمنى مثل هذه التصريحات ان يغلق مثل هذا
الباب ولا نتمنى ايضا روسيا تذهب بمثل هذه
الاتجاهات في المرحله المستقبليه
السيناريوهات التي قد تتعامل مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
السيناريو الاول او النقطه الاولى انه نحن
لا نتمنى ان تتصاعد الحرب لمستويات اعلى
مما هي عليه على اقل تقدير بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وان تستمر كما هي في المرحله
المستقبليه وهذا يعطي المملكه مساحه اكبر
ايضا من مواصله مثل هذه الخطوات الايجابيه
نحو المستقبل السيناريو الثاني ان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه عندما تستمع لمثل هذه
التوجهات الروسيه هي تتمنى ان تعلم لماذا
ايضا هذه النقطه هاي في الاهميه اذا كان
الطرف الاخر الركاني على سبيل المثال لديه
وجهه نظر فلتنقل هذه وجهه النظر من روسيا
الى اوكرانيا ومن اوكرانيا الى روسيا
وايضا المجتمع الاخر المهم جدا وهو
المجتمع الغربي ايضا في مثل هذه الازمات
هذا السيناريو تعمل عليه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وقد تعمل عليها السياسه خارجيه
السعوديه انها تتصاعد مثل هذه الازمات
السيناريو ايضا الاخر الذي يتعلق بمثل هذه
المسائل وهو ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تحرص ان تحافظ على علاقاتها مع روسيا
كعلاقات جيده وان تكون هذه العلاقات فيما
يبني السلام والامن والسلم والسفر حتى على
المستويات الاقليميه والمستويات الخارجيه
لانه خوفنا
في المنطقه انه مرحله هذا التصعيد قد يجعل
الامور خارج نطاق السيطره لجميع الاطراف
وهنا بالتالي يكون هناك اثر مباشر على
المنطقه من هذه الحرب اللا شك في ذلك ونحن
قريبين جدا من الجغرافيا الروسيه
والجغرافيا الاوروبيه سوف تؤثر علينا بشكل
مباشر وسوف تتاثر ايضا مجالات اخرى كما
مجالات الطاقه مجالات الامن الغذائي
مجالات
المحاربه التنظيمات والجماعات الارهابيه
قد اوروبا بعد ذلك تدفع ثمن ايضا كبير جدا
في دخول في الزراعات قد تدخل ايضا منطقه
اخرى في داخل روسيا لمسائل اخرى في وسط
اسيا وغيرها ولذلك مساله اقفال باب السلام
لا اعتقد انها سياسه روسيه حقيقيه بقدمها
تكون سياسه روسيه دبلوماسيه للحصول على
مكاسب من قبل المجتمع الغربي على سبيل
المثال وبالتالي المملكه هذا السيناريو
الرئيسي هي ذهبت به وسوف تعمل عليه اللي
هو تحقيق اكبر قدر ممكن من الاستماع الى
وجهه النظر الروس وبصفتها مقبوله لدى
الاوكرانيين ايضا قد تنقل هذه وجهه النظر
لاوكرانيا
لكن هناك ملف اخطر مرتبط
بهذا الامر الان او بتطورات هذه الحرب
والكل يشير الى ان الحليف الاقرب الان الى
لروسيا في هذه الحرب هو ايران ايران وحسب
اخر التقارير تتحدث عن مغادره سفينتين
تحملان الكثير من الحاويات المليئه
بالاسلحه المتوجهه الى روسيا روسيا كذلك
وحسب التقارير هي تدرس الان امكانيه امداد
ايران بالطائرات سوخوي 35 بالاضافه الى
بطاريه صواريخ اس 400 وهنا سيكون لذلك
تاثير كبير على توازن القوه الموجود في
هذه المنطقه وهذا يعني ان هناك اثر مباشر
لهذه الحرب
ستذهب اليه المنطقه اذا ما تصاعدته
وبالتالي دكتور هنا ما هو موقف السعوديه
خاصه اذا ما بالتاكيد ان هذا الملف كان
مطروحا من قبل وزير الخارجيه السعودي في
هذه الجلسه التي تمت اليوم مع وزير
الخارجي وان لم يتم الاشاره اليه نعم هو
نعم تحقيق الامن والم الوطني للمقرب
السعوديه هدف رئيسي لسياسه الدوله
السعوديه ولجميع المسؤوليه الدوله ان
يخدمه نحن هنا نتمنى ان روسيا ان لا تذهب
بمثل هذه الاتجاهات نعم هناك اخبار تعلقت
بالسوخوي وغيرها وهذه اشاره بالنسبه لنا
تعتبر ليست اشاره ايجابيه بحكم انه ايران
معلوم نظامها السياسي متطرف يدعم
التنظيمات والجماعات الارهابيه تتدخل في
شؤون الدول الاقليميه وهذا وهي امكاناتها
محدوده وعليها عقوبات فنحن نتساءل هنا في
المنطقه ان حصلت ايران على مزيد من
الاسلحه النوعيه والمتقدمه جدا كطائره
فماذا سوف تمارس ايران من تحديد فيما
يتعلق بالتوازن الاقليمي نعم سوف يكون
هناك توازن اقليمي غير جيد بالنسبه
للمنطقه كلها دول المسالمه والمعتدره في
المنطقه السعوديه من الواجب عليها ان تحمي
نفسها وتحمي سياساتها سيناريو اخطر قد
تتعرض ايران لضربات الاسرائيليين
والامريكان وغيرهم وهذا يعرضون ايضا
لمسائل في المنطقه قد تصاعد الاقليميه
وبالتالي قد تدخل روسيا ايضا في حال ساعدت
ايضا في حرب اكبر مع الامريكيين وغيرهم
وبالتالي مثل هذه السياسات اعتقد انها سوف
تكلف الروس كثيرا في مستوى السياسه
الدبلوماسي او الدبلوماسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه ونحن سيكون لها اثر بمعنى صحيح ان
كل هذه التطورات قد تجعل المملكه تغادر
منطقه الحياده التي هي عليها الان وتتجه
ربما في حاله تم وهو المتوقع ان يكون هناك
استقطاب حاد
تاثيرات هذه الحرب وفي حال تصاعدت الحرب
من حرب اوكرانيا روسيه الى ما اوروبيه
اوروبيه او الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط من
اعتقد ان المركب السعوديه سوف تجد نفسها
في حاجه الى ان تحمي امنها بحكم انه
الايرانيون سوف يمارسون مزيد من الارهاب
والتطرف بمن يقف معها من المجتمع الذي يقف
ضد ايران واتحدث عن مجتمع الغربي
تحديداكيه بحكم التحالف الدولي
والعلاقات المتقدمه جدا
وبالتالي سوف يكون المملكه السعوديه اعتقد
انها سوف تذهب بالاتجاه الذي لا نتمناه
وهو ضد روسيا بحكم ان روسيا تساعد ايران
على الحصول على اسلحه لقد تكلفنا في
المركبه السعوديه ونحن امننا هو الهدا
الهدف الاول والثاني والثالث بالنسبه
على الامن والسلم والاستقلال نحن هذه
السيناريوهات لا نتمنى ان
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه الروسي اتمنى ان لا
تكون حقيقيا اتمنى ان تكون فقط
للدبلوماسيه والحصول على ضغط اما ان ذهبت
باتجاهات الاخرى فاعتقد ان الروس من
الذكاء بمكان ان يدرسوا العواقب ويدرسوا
ما هي التبعات التي سوف تحدث
لروسيا ولاوروبا وللمنطقه هنا شكرا جزيلا
لك دكتور ابراهيم النحاس استاد العلوم
السياسيه عضو مجلس شكرا لك شكرا
وحاول ازمه في اليمن اكد وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان انه اولويه
المملكه حاليا في اليمن هي الوصول لوقف
اطلاق نار دائم ثم اطلاق عمليه سياسيه
مشيرا في مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره
الى ان الحوار جاري العمل في هذا المساء
الاولويه الان هي وقف اطلاق نار ومن ثم
اطلاق الحوار خلاف ذلك لا اريد ان اخوض في
اي تفاصيل تاكيدا او نفيا لانها ليس مفيدا
لبصاره
المفاوضات لكن وقت نؤكد ان اهتمام المملكه
حاليا هو ايجاد سبيل لوقف القتال بشكل
دائم ومن ثم اطلاق حوار يمني
يضمن استقرار اليمن ويضمن استقلاليه اليمن
ويضمن بعد ذلك ايضا ازدهار اليمن وهذا هي
الاولويه لدينا في ملف الطاقه كد وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيركيلافروف على التنفيذ
المستمر للتزامات اوبك بلس وبدوره يشار
وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل ابن فرحان الى
ان المملكه ملتزمه باتفاق ابيك بلس مؤكدا
ان هناك تنسيقا وثيقا بين السعوديه وروسيا
فيما يتعلق بملف الطاقه يذكر ان اعضاء
اوبيك بلس كانوا قد اتفقوا على خفض
الانتاج بواقع مليوني برميل يوميا في
نوفمبر الماضي
تمكنت عليه اهميه التنسيق الوثيق بين
المملكه وروسيا في اسواق الطاقه والتزام
المملكه الثابت باتف بلس وعلى ضمان
استقرار اسواق الطاقه العالميه بما يخدم
مصلحه المنتجين والمستهلكين على حد سواء
رابعه مستمره فيها بعد اقل
السعوديه تتعهد بتخصيص 800 مليون دولار
على شكل قروض للبلدان الاقل لنموا
اهلا بكم من جديد ضمن اعمال مؤتمر الامم
المتحده الخامس المعني باقل البلدان نموا
المقام في العاصمه القطريه الدوحه اعلانات
السعوديه تخصيصها قروضا تنمويه بقيمه 800
مليون دولار لتمويل مشروعات انمائيه
للبلدان الاقل نموا في كل من افريقيا
واسيا ومناطق اخرى من العالم وزير
الاقتصاد والتخطيط السعودي فيصل الابراهيم
اكد ان السعوديه ملتزمه بالعمل الجاد لدعم
البلدان الاقل نموا من خلال جهودها الضخمه
في مساعدات الدول على التجاوز ظروفها
وتحدياتها مضيفا بانها قدمت منذ عام 1975
وحتى نهايه العمل 2022 ما مجموعه 330 قرضا
للدول الاقل نموا لتمويل 308 مشاريع
وبرامج تنمويه بمبلغ اجمالي تجاوز سته
مليارات دولار استفادت منها 35 دوله من
الدول الاقل نموا
في الرياض التشهد التي تشهد اليوم انطلاقه
منتدى بيبان 23 تحت شعار فرص تصنع الرياده
يشارك في الملتقى المقرر ان يستمر حتى 13
من مارس الجاريه اكثر من 350 متحدثا محليا
وعالميا وسبعمائه وخمسين عارضا من رواد
الاعمال المحليين والعالمين 120 جهه ممكنه
للمنشاءات الصغيره والمتوسطه ستشارك ايضا
في الملتقى لباحث الفرص الاستثماريه
والتمويليه اضافه الى الخدمات التي تقدمها
اربعون جهه حكوميه للمنشات المشاركه
سيحتضن الملتقى نهائيات مسابقه كاس العالم
لرياده الاعمال بمشاركه اكثر من 200 دوله
وتعد اول واكبر بطوله من نوعها على مستوى
العالم بمجموع جوائز يبلغ مليون دولار
من ملتقى بيبان في الرياض ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز حياك الله نواف
ما هو جديد بيبان
نعم خالد لا زلنا في بدايه بيبان وهو في
النسخه الاولى
وللتتحت ابواب هذا الملتقى الضخم الذي
يوفر فرصه مهمه لرواد الاعمال وايضا
المبتدئين في الانشطه التجاريه بالسعوديه
من خلال العارضين المتواجدين في ملتقى
بيبان الذي يستمر على مدى خمسه ايام
سبعمائه وخمسين عارض يمثلون ثلاث وخمسين
دوله يتواجدون للبحث عن الفرص وايضا تقديم
المشوره والمعرفه لرواد الاعمال من خلال
الورش والجلسات والحواريه التي يشارك فيها
متحدثا محليا ودوليا سنكون الان في جوله
على بيبان مع مدير عام تطوير الاعمال
المهندس منذر الفراج اهلا وسهلا مهندس
منذر في البدايه 53 دوله مشاركه ما هي
الفرص التي
تلك الدول والعارضين جميل الحقيقه
الجاذبيه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه هي
التي اكدت على توافد هذا الكم الكبير من
رواد الاعمال من مختلف دول العالم محليا
واقليميا وعالميا وهي تعزيزا الحقيقه
لمكانه المملكه ودورها الراسخ كمركز ريادي
وجاذب لرواد الاعمال وتعزيزا الحقيقه
لمكانه المملكه الاقتصاديه التي تساعد على
تعزيز التواصل بين رواد الاعمال واصحاب
المنشات الصغيره والمتوسطه وصانعي القرار
والمستثمرين واصحاب الافكار المبتكره نعم
مهندس منذر يعني خلال الفتره الاخيره هناك
تعثر لبعض المشاريع المبتدئه لدى
السعوديين خصوصا في قطاع المطاعم والمقاهي
وقطاعات اخرى كيف يقلل ملتقى بيبان من فرص
التعثر لدى
في المشاريع جميل الملتقى يحتوي على تسعه
ابواب يعني من احد هذه الابواب باب النمو
والذي يعزز نمو المنشات الصغيره المتوسطه
القائمه التي تمارس اعمالها من خلال
العديد من البرامج التوعيه والبرامج
الارشاديه بالاضافه للمرشدين المختصين في
مختلف القطاعات وكذلك ايضا مقابله اصحاب
القرار الذين يساعدون اصحاب المنشات
الصغيره المتوسطه ورواد الاعمال على ضمان
الاستدامه والاستمراريه في ممارسه اعمالهم
وتحقيق اعلى النتائج ما هي الفئات
المدعوه لملتقى بيبان من رواد الاعمال
وايضا من مختلف الفئات الاخرى الحقيقه
جميع رواد الاعمال سواء اصحاب المنشات
القائمه او من لديهم افكار يرغبون في
تطوير وتمضيج هذه الافكار بحيث تصبح يعني
على ارض الواقع وكذلك ايضا
اصحاب رؤوس الاموال الذين لديهم الرغبه
للاستثمار في رواد الاعمال والاستثمار في
افكار نوعيه ومبتكره تقدم من خلال هذا
الملتقى اليوم نجد ان الملتقى يوفر فرصه
كبيره للجمع بين رواد الاعمال واصحاب
الافكار والمشاريع وكذلك المستثمرين
واصحاب روسيا الاموال والجهات التمويليه
التي ترغب بتعزيز مكانتها وتعزيز
استثماراتها من خلال العديد من البرامج
التي تطرحها والافكار والفرص المقدمه من
خلال المنشات الصغيره المتوسطه ورواد
الاعمال كل الشكر لك مهندس منذر اذا خالد
امام هذا الملتقى خمس ايام
سيشهد العديد من الاتفاقيات هناك 650 فرصه
متاحه امام الجهات 650 فرصه استثماريه وهو
من المتوقع ان نشهد اعلانات كبيره بارقام
مرتفعه حول ملتقى بيبان والفرص المتاحه
فيه شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من بيبان في الرياض
مراسل العربيه
في الرابع ايضا بعد قليل
وزير السياحه السعودي يعلن عن زياره للنجم
ليونيل ميسي الى السعوديه خلال مارس
الجاري
ونحن جاهزون
للعمل مع الاطراف
للبحث عن الحلول السلميه وقد سبق خطوه
سعوديه جديده في ازمه اوكرانيا وزير
الخارجيه يؤكد استعداد الرياض للوساطه
وموسكو طرح
رياض تدشن ملتقى ببان 23 بطوله عالميه
لرواد الاعمال واكثر من مئه الف مشترك
ازمه جسر الملك فهد في شرق السعوديه تستمر
تعطل يربك حركه السير ولا تجاوب حتى الان
والسعوديه تعلن السماح للمقيمين في دول
الخليج بالتاشيره السياحيه تتيح لهم
العمره والاستثناءات في المهن
الكثير من الانتظار لهذه القمه الكبيره
والمنتظره
صراع الصداره في الدوري السعودي يشتعل
الاتحاد والنصر على ملعب الجوهره في جده
اهلا بكم من جديد في العاصمه السعوديه
رياض زارا اعضاء بعثه المكتب الدولي
للمعارض الاسبوع الموقع المقترح لمعرض
رياض اكسبو 2020 وتم خلال الزياره الاطلاع
على المخطط الرئيسي للموقع الذي يمتد على
مساحه سته ملايين متر مربع وذلك خلال
اليوم الثالث لزياره البعثه للرياض
الهادفه الى مناقشه ملف المملكه لاستضافه
معرض اكسبو الدولي 2023
اعلنت وزاره السياحه السعوديه السماحه
لجميع المقيمين في دول مجلس التعاون
بالحصول على تاشيره سياحيه ايا كانت المهن
التي يعملون بها واشارت وزاره السياحه الى
ان هذه التاشيره السياحيه ستمكن الحاصلين
عليها من المقيمين في دول الخليج من اداء
العمره فضلا عن الانشطه السياحيه الاخرى
وفي جميع مناطق المملكه الزميله العنود
العبدلي تاخذنا لنتعرف اكثر على التسهيلات
والتاشيرات التي تقدمها السعوديه للتعزيز
السياحه
تسهيلات ومشاريع ضخمه يشهدها القطاع
السياحي والذي تسعى السعوديه الى تعزيزه
من خلال برامج رؤيه 2030 السعوديه
مشاهدينا تسعى لرفع نسبه مشاركه القطاع في
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي الى عشره في المئه
بحلول عشرين ثلاثين ولتحقيق هذا الهدف
قامت السعوديه بانشاء مشاريع ضخمه واتخذت
ايضا خطوات مهمه لتعزيز قطاع السياحه خلال
السنوات الماضيه هذا الامر رفع في اسهام
القطاع السياحي في الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
من ثلاثه في المئه في 2019 الى اربعه في
المئه بنهايه عام 2022
واحده من اهم تلك الخطوات هي اصدار تاشيره
مرور الكترونيه لزياره للقادمين جوا وتمتد
صلاحيه التاشيره المجانيه الى ثلاثه اشهر
كما يمكن لحامليها اقامه في السعوديه لمده
اربعه ايام والتنقل في مختلف المناطق
السعوديه وتتيح ايضا للقادمين اداء العمره
وبالعوده الى عام 2019 نجد ان السعوديه
بدات بفتح ابوابها للعالم حيث اتاحت اصدار
التاشيرات السياحيه لحامل جنسيه 49 دوله
كما سمحت في العام الماضي من خلال تعديلات
لائحه تاشيره الزياره لغرض السياحه
للمقيمين في دول الخليج العربي بالحصول
على التاشيره السياحيه الكترونيا وفي
العام الماضي ايضا وتحديدا في شهر نوفمبر
اصدرت وزاره الخارجيه تاشيره الزياره
الشخصيه التي تمكن المواطنين من دعوه
اصدقائهم لزياره السعوديه
اعلن وزير السياحه السعوديه احمد الخطيب
ان النجم الارجنتيني لاعب فريق باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي ليونيل ميسي
سفيره سياحه السعوديه سيزور البلاد خلال
الشهر الجاري برفقه عائلته واصدقائه
للاستمتاع بالوجهات السياحيه هذه هي
الزياره الثانيه لميسي في اقل من عام منذ
اعلانه سفيرا للسياحه السعوديه في مايو
الماضي
[موسيقى]
لليوم الرابع على التوالي لا يزال جسر
الملك فهد الرابط بين السعوديه والبحرين
يشهد ازمه مروريه خانقه وذلك بعد اعلان
المؤسسه العامه لجسر الملك فهد اغلاق بعض
من بواباته بسبب الصيانه مؤكده ان القرار
جاء لبدء اعمال التوسعه والصيانه لزياده
الطاقه الاستيعابيه على مراحل الوسط
تساؤلات عده عن اليه عمل الجسر الحالي
وتكرار التعطل في انجاز عمليه عبور
القادمين والمغادرين وكان جسر الملك فهد
سجل عبوره على عدد مسافرين منذ افتتاحه
قبل نحو 36 عاما وتجاوز عددهم حجز ال 136
الف مسافر في يوم واحد
من امام جسر الملك فهد ينضم الينا مراسل
العربي عبد الرحمن العصيمي حياك الله عبد
الرحمن
هل ما زال التكدس والازدحام والاختناق
وسيد الموقف
نعم خالد لا ي هل هو سيد الموقف لليوم
الرابع على التوالي والاسباب غير معلومه
تواصلنا مع الجوازات السعوديه مع الجمارك
ايضا مع المؤسسه العامه لجسر الملك فهد
ولكن جميع هذه الجهات العامله والمسؤوله
عن جسر الملك فهد لم تتجاوب معنا ورفضت
التعليق على هذه الازمه بحسب المصادر بعض
الموظفين اخبرونا بان هناك تعطيل في
السيستم الخاص بالجوازات البعض الاخر
وبحسب تغريده لمؤسسه العامه للجسم بل هناك
اعمال الصيانه لكن لا احد يدري ما هو
السبب الحقيقي سادع زميلي المصور ينقلكم
الاجواء والتكدس والازدحام الذي نشاهده
طبعا نحن الان امام بوابات الرسوم الخاصه
بجسر الملك فهد وهي التي تعتبر يعني
بوابه الجسر الملك فهد نشاهد السيارات
طبعا هنا نحن في الطريق المؤدي الى الجسر
من ناحيه حي الجسر ازدحام شديد خالد منذ
ساعات الصباح الاولى والازدحام يزداد اولا
باول نشاهد ايضا المرور وهو يغلق المدخل
للجسر طبعا هناك خطه وضعها مرور مدينه
الخبر لتقليل الازدحام لكن يبدو هذه الخطه
حتى الان لم تساعد المواطنين في تجاوز
الازدحام والاكتظاظ على الجسر نشاهد ايضا
بعض المواطنين الذي قرر ان يرتاح على
المسطحات الخضراء الاطفال النساء بانتظار
الانفراجه وفتح
[موسيقى]
البوابات بوابات الرسوم الخاصه بجسر الملك
فهد ومن ثم
بوبات الجمارك او المنافذ الجمارك
والجوازات طبعا من الجهات البحرين خالد
الامور تسير بانسيابيه تامه ولا يوجد اي
تعطيل بالنسبه للجوازات او الجمارك
الازدحام وال فقط في الجانب السعودي طبعا
المواطنون عبروا للعربيه قبل قليل عن
استيائهم لماذا لا يوجد حلول لهذا
الازدحام اذا كان هناك مشكله في السيستم
او مشكله في
السؤال الاخر خالد لماذا
بالضبط
والسؤال خالد انه لماذا جسر الملك فهد
المؤسسه قررت ان تقوم بالصيانه
والانشاءات في هذا التوقيت الذي هو اجازه
المدارس طبعا واقبال العائلات وايضا هناك
مواطنون بحرينيون خالد ايضا عالقون منذ
يومين تقريبا وقرروا ان ياخذوا بعض الشقق
هنا في مدينه الخبر
حتى تتضح لهم الصوره وهل يستطيعون الدخول
الى مملكه البحرين مواطنين بحرينيين فما
بالك بالسياح السعوديين او ايضا من لديه
اعمال او اشغال في البحرين يعني اذا اتيت
مبكرا الساعه السادسه
السابعه صباحا
ربما تستغرق تقريبا حوالي ست الى سبع
ساعات لدخول مملكه البحرين وهذا يعني وقت
يعني طويل جدا اذا حلفك الحظ واستطعت
الدخول لكن اذا لم تستطع للصعب للغايه
خالد ان تدخل الى مملكه البحرين في وقت
سريع طبعا هناك تطبيق هائل اسمه تطبيق جسر
تابع للمؤسسه العامه للجسمك فهد من خلال
هذا التطبيق تستطيع معرفه الازدحام
المروري داخل الجسر سنقوم الان بتجربه
لهذا التطبيق ونريكم كيف هو حال الازدحام
داخل الجسر من الجانب السعودي كما نشاهد
هذه الصوره
من خلال تطبيق جسر طبعا هنا الجانب
السعودي هناك تقريبا اكثر من 17 مسارا
للسيارات للجمارك السعوديه
المسارات التي تعمل هي فقط
خمس او ست مسارات خالد كما نشاهد في
الصوره هذا بس حي لتطبيق جسر الملك فهد
من خلاله يستطيع المسافر ان يرصد حركه
المرور الخروج والدخول من الجانب البحريني
او الجانب السعودي نشاهد الاكتظاظ
والازدحام لا يزال موجود في جسر الملك فهد
اسئله عده والمواطنون ينتظرون ربما خلال
ساعات المساء المتاخره او ربما يوم غد
يكون هناك انفراج اكثر ويتم حل هذه
المشكله التي لا تزال غامضه حتى الان طبعا
خالد هناك تغريده غرد بها حساب جسر الملك
فهد ساقوم باستعراضها ايضا لكم التي نشاهد
على تويتر التقرير تقول بان هناك توسعه
لمنطقه الاجراءات هذه التغريده كانت في
تاريخ 6 مارس شيء تقريبا قبل
ايام ثلاثه لكن حتى الان
التسلسلات
في معدات تكون موجوده في اشياء مشاهده على
الارض اذا كان في توسعه للمسارات احنا
اللي نشوفه انه ما في اي حضور لاي شيء من
القبيله من قبل انت تواصلت مع من بس عبد
الرحمن حتى بس تتضح الصوره في تواصلت مع
المتحدث الرسمي تواصلت مع المتحدث الرسمي
للجوازات السعوديه الرائد ناصر العتيبي
تواصلت ايضا مع الرئيس التنفيذي لمؤسسه
العامه لجسر الملك فهد تواصلت ايضا مع
الجمارك مع الاستاذ فايز الحربي المسؤول
عن التواصل الحكومي في الجمارك لكن لم
يعلقوا او يقوموا بايضاح الصوره بشكل كامل
شكرا لك على هذه الصوره الواضحه والوافيه
عبد الرحمن العصيمي مراسل العربيه من جسر
الملك فهد
العثمان فنان سعوديه يقوم بصناعه مجسمات
من الطين يستنسخ من خلالها حارات وقصور في
الرياض القديمه قام بصناعه اكثر من 200
مجسم من خامات طبيعيه من البيئه تفاصيل مع
غاده الفهد
25 عاما امضاها الفنان السعودي هاني
العثماني في صناعه مجسمات من الطين واخشاب
الاثل يستنسخ من خلالها حارات وقصور
الرياضيه القديمه متبوعا بشغفه وتعلقه
بذكريات يخشى عليها ان تنتظر
طبعا البدايات كانت بسيطه يعني استخدام
خامات بسيطه شوي شوي بدات اشتغل على
الخامات اللي هو الطبيعيه عشان اعطي تصور
كامل للمبنى يصير نفسه المجسم يعني من
العواد الاثيل من التربه الزراعيه من
الشبابيك اللي موجوده استخدمنا خامات
بسيطه تعطيني تصور كامل البيت اللي انا
شفته على الطبيعه اكثر من 200 مجسم صنعها
بعد
الدقيقه مثل هذا البيت وسط العاصمه الرياض
الذين نالت منه عوامل الزمن
كما قام بصناعه مجسمات لمعالم معروفه مثل
قصر سلوى في الدرعيه وقصر المربع في
الرياض
طبعا انا اركز اساسا على
اللي موجود دائما في الطبيعه اللي هو
التربه بانواعها طبعا في تربه زراعيه في
تربه يعني شوي غامقه عشان تعطي زيت
زي ما هو في الصوره يكون في المجسم
الاعواد نفس الطريقه اختار الاعواد بعنايه
تكون قديمه ما تكون عود جديده او زي كذا
او انها شغل مصنعي لا طبعا اعواد زي اللي
طايح من الاشجار زي عواد الاثا او زي كذا
يستخدم هاني التربه الطينيه ومواد وخامات
طبيعيه من البيئه التي يعيش فيها ويتعامل
معها بطريقه ابداعيه تبهر زوار المهرجانات
والفعاليات التي يشارك بها غاده الفهد
العربيه الرياض
تحتفل السعوديه بيوم العالم قبل تساوي
الليل مع النهار باربعه ايام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليوم الذي اقر فيها الملك المؤسس الملك
عبد العزيز طيب الله تراه العلم بشكله
الحالي هو يوم العلم وذلك في 27 ذي الحجه
1355 الموافق 11 مارس
1937 وهو نفس البيرق والرايه التي حملها
جند الدوله السعوديه الاولى والثانيه قبل
300 سنه والعلم رمز الحاكم والمحكوم
والدوله وللرمز دلاله واحده ومعنى محدد
يتفق الجميع على معرفتها هو علمنا رمز
الشهاده والتوحيد هو علمنا رمز الرخاء
والنماء والتطور هو علمنا نعشقه طوال
العام ونحتفل فيه في يوم 11 مارس رفرف يا
رايه العز من فوق الغمام وابشر ابشر يا
وطنا ليحان الوعد كلنا من دون حدك على خط
الامام ليش تعلم من نار الايام بالراجل
ورعد
[تصفيق]
ونحتفل باليوم الوطني قبل تساوي الليل مع
النهار باربعه ايام الاعتدال الخريفي في
23 سبتمبر ونحتفل بيوم العالم قبل تساوي
الليل مع النهار باربعه ايام الاعتدال
الربيعي في 11 مارس وكلاهما تكون الاجواء
في غايه الاعتدال واللطف هذه بلادي وانا
طول يطاولها في ساحه المجد او نجم يدانيها
ومهره العرب الاحرار لو عطشت نصب من دمنا
ماء
ونرويها
[موسيقى]
اعلن تيك توك انه سيسمح لبعض صناع المحتوى
بانتاج مقاطع اطول بمقابل مادي فاتحا بذلك
بابا جديدا لمستخدمه لكسب المال وبحسب
الخبراء ستتيح الخدمه الجديده سيريز لصناع
المحتوى المؤهلين نشرى مجموعات تصل الى 80
مقطعا مصورا طويلا تصل مده كل منها الى 20
دقيقه في حين يسمح تيك توك حاليا بعشر
دقائق كحد اقصى للمقاطع المصوره
لمنافسه يوتيوب تيك توك يتيح لمستخدمه
انتاج مقاطع مصوره تصل مدتها الى 20 دقيقه
واذا تجاوز الفيديو هذه المده فسيكون
بمقابل مادي فاتحا بذلك بابا جديدا
لمستخدميه لكسب المال اطول مده يسمح بها
تيك توك للمقاطع المصوره حاليا هي عشر
دقائق لكن بعد تفعيل خدمته الجديده سيريز
بامكان صناع المحتوى بث 80 مقطعا مصورا
مده كل منها 20 دقيقه يامل تيك توك
بمنافسه يوتيوب عملاق جوجل حيث يتيح
الفرصه لمستخدمي لتقديم محتوى مثل عرض
جداول البيانات والتمارين البدنيه ووصفات
الطعام
بلغ عدد مستخدمي تيك توك مليار مستخدم
ناشط شهريا في سبتمبر 2021
ختم الرابع
ونحن جاهزون
للعمل مع الاطراف
للبحث عن الحلول السلميه وقد سبق انساهمنا
فيما خطوه سعوديه جديده في ازمه اوكرانيا
وزير الخارجيه يؤكد استعداد الرياض للوسط
وموسكو ترحب
رياض تدشن ملتقى ببان 23 بطوله عالميه
لرواد الاعمال واكثر من مئه الف مشترك
السعوديه تعلن السماح للمقيمين في دول
الخليج بتاشيره سياحيه تتيح لهم العمره
ولا استثناءات في المئه
كثير من الانتظار لهذه القمه الكبيره
والمنتظره
صراع الصداره في الدوري السعودي
الاتحاد والنصر في ملعب الجوهره في جده
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]